[Musik]
967 war ich zu guter letzt stützpunkt
kommandant des stützpunktes in obergurgl
ich war dafür aber nicht vorgesehen
sondern als kunden kommandant des
dortigen stützpunkt ist durch den
ausfall des kommandanten musste der
nächste nachrücken und das war ich unter
durch motiv stützpunkts kommandant also
ich war damals zugführer mit knopf wie
man so schön sagt und ich glaube
geworden
für diesen einsatz bestens vorbereitet
und bestens ausgebildet wir kommen aus
der südsteiermark und das ist eine ebene
hügelige gegend und gebirge ist uns an
und für sich fremd und wir haben im
alltag gebirge nicht erlebt in keiner
form unser damaliger
bataillonskommandant verlegte uns jedoch
14 tage vor dem einsatz auf diese leute
um uns an die höhenluft zu gewinnen und
wir mussten dann dort im dortigen
alpinen gelände viele masche durchführen
die wir wo wir dann lernen wie man sich
eigentlich in einen alpinen gelände zu
bewegen hat also ich habe an den einsatz
nur positive erinnerungen
es war vom ersten bis zum letzten tag
sehr interessant diesen meines vorgarten
im einsatz teilweise unter großen
entbehrungen zu erleben und viele
wichtige erfahrungswerte bekam ich durch
die zivilisten in obergurgl die ja
gewohnt waren sich in diesem gelände zu
bewegen wie man sich dort bewegt zum
beispiel das mit dem steiger essen zum
beispiel dass man die gebirgsstrecke zum
beispiel das wie man sich am ketscher
teilt und das war für mich schon ein
sehr wertvoller impuls der das ganze
leben diese verrückte und ich bin sehr
dankbar dafür denn ich bin heute schon
agitation und bin gerne im gebirge
unterwegs wandere gern am berg und da
kann ich all diese erfahrungen immer
wieder anwenden also angst hatte niemand
aber respekt möchte ich sagen
also wir hatten schon respekt es war für
uns alle der erste einsatz überhaupt wir
wussten ja nicht was wirklich war
wir sind ja schon informiert worden ob
er bekannten der großen zusammenhang
liegt und hatten dadurch vor diesen
einsatz respekt und werden dann auch
unter uns gegenseitig respekt zu haben
weil wir dahinter kamen dass gerade in
solchen situationen werden an der zwölf
wochen im einsatz
wichtige menschliche eigenschaften in
den vordergrund treten
das heißt die eigenschaften des
charakters dann wichtiger als die des
geistes